un granjero usó postes para construir
una cerca para el caballo hansel y el
poni pauli el granjero usó 26 postes
para construir la cerca del caballo
hansel y 19 postes para la cerca del
poni pauli cuántos postes usó en total
el granjero y si quieres te recomiendo
que pongas una pausa y trates de
resolver este problema por tu cuenta
bueno voy a suponer que ya lo intentaste
entonces vamos a pensar cómo resolverlo
juntos en este problema cuál es la idea
general tenemos un granjero que quiso
construir una cerca para el caballo
hansel y el poni pauli y de hecho hasta
los tenemos dibujados por aquí aunque se
parecen mucho este caballo y este pony
pero bueno el chiste es que el granjero
usó 26 postes para construir está cerca
que está cerca tienen 26 postes
la verdad no me he puesto a contar todos
estos postres pero voy a suponer que en
efecto aquí si hay 26 postes alrededor
del caballo hansel y después uso 19
postes para la cerca del poni pauli ok
entonces está cerca
tiene 19 postes y queremos saber cuántos
postes uso en total en total así es que
qué es lo que quieren que hagamos que
sumemos o que restamos porque nos están
preguntando cuántos postes uso en total
y para contar todos los postes que uso
en total tenemos que contar los postes
que uso en la cerca de hansel
y sumarlo a la cantidad de postes que
uso para la cerca del pont y pauline así
es que tenemos que sumar estos dos
números tenemos que sumar los 26 postes
de la cerca del caballo hansel más los
19 postes de la cerca del poni pauli así
es que tenemos 26 postes para la cerca
del caballo hansel 26
y le sumamos 19 postes para la cerca del
poni pauli 19 y los estamos sumando
porque queremos saber el total de postes
usados para estas cercas y el total en
la cerca del caballo hansel y la cerca
del poni pauli que hay vamos a empezar
por las unidades tenemos seis unidades
más nueve unidades y eso son 15 unidades
pero 15 lo podemos dividir en 10 más 5
aunque lo podemos dividir en una decena
y cinco unidades y ponemos la decena por
aquí porque aquí es donde están las
decenas y aquí las unidades también
podemos decir que ponemos aquí el 5 y
llevamos una aunque ahí tenemos quien se
y luego pues tenemos una decena más dos
decenas más
otra decena y uno más dos más uno es
cuatro entonces aquí tenemos
cuatro decenas así es que tenemos 45 que
hay 45 postes en total en las dos cercas
ahora puede ser que algunos de ustedes
hayan querido restar 26 menos 19 y eso
tendría mucho sentido si nos hubieran
preguntado cuántos postes más tiene la
cerca del caballo hansel que la cerca
del poni pauli
o si nos hubieran preguntado cuántos
postes le faltan a la cerca del poni
pauli para hacer del mismo tamaño que la
cerca del caballo hansel pero no nos
están preguntando eso lo que nos
preguntaron fue cuántos postes usó en
total el granjero y por eso tenemos que
sumar